peter duce is at the white house with
new information on the use of booster
shots from the most vulnerable americans
but first to state department
correspondent rich edson and what some
say was the true genesis of the
coronavirus good evening rich good
evening brett a world health
organization expert tells danish
television that it is probable a
researcher in a wuhan lab working with
bats may have been the first human
infected with covid19 this is scientist
peter ben embrick and he says he's part
of a documentary on danish television
airing tonight where he claims he had
concerns about safety standards at a lab
in wuhan and that chinese government
officials pressured the who to drop any
investigation into the possibility the
virus began in a lab earlier this year
the who team released a report claiming
a lab leak was extremely unlikely ben
emerick now notes in that investigation
scientists were denied access to lab
books and documents he says the who team
only received a presentation ben embrick
notes however there is no direct
evidence that the outbreak is related to
the research conducted at wuhan's labs
just this afternoon the w.h.o released a
statement calling on quote all
governments to de-politicize the
situation and cooperate to accelerate
the origin's studies that includes a
potential lab leak china has criticized
any suggestion that covet 19 began in a
lab and has instead demanded the who
investigate u.s bio labs one former
state department official who
investigated the origins of the virus
under the previous administration claims
the chinese government is covering up
the lab leak
in the chinese cesspool of lies they've
been propagating from day one on this
thing
um
when you know rather than looking for a
virus in its origins they seem to know
where it came from from day one and they
started propagating a cover story
earlier this month republicans on the
house foreign affairs committee released
a report claiming the preponderance of
evidence suggests the virus was
accidentally released from a wuhan lab
the biden administration has initiated
an intelligence review into the origins
of the pandemic that report is due the
week after next brett richardson the
state department rich thanks hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else